we have sadly tragic news from ukraine
where an american journalist has been
killed by russian forces and another
journalist has been shot
there were there were some incorrect
things reported about this story and
we're going to correct those the
jerusalem post reporting american
journalists killed another wounded by
russian forces near kiev
the slain journalist was identified by
ukrainian police as a 51 51-year-old u.s
citizen and media correspondent
an american
journalist was killed and another
wounded by russian forces in irpin near
the ukrainian capital of kiev the killed
journalist was identified by ukrainian
police as brett renaud a 51 year old
journalist filmmaker and u.s citizen
while the ukrainian authorities
initially identified renaud as the new
york times correspondent
he was not in ukraine on behalf of the
time so that's an important detail in
the new york times also putting this out
this doesn't make it any less tragic but
initially it was reported as a
journalist working for the new york
times in ukraine was shot and killed
it happens not to be true
the new york times putting out a
statement saying we are deeply saddened
to hear of brent renaud's death brent
was a talented filmmaker who had
contributed to the new york times over
the years though he had contributed to
the times in the past most recently 2015
he was not on assignment for any desk at
the times in ukraine
early reports that he worked for time
circulated because he was wearing a
times press badge that he had been
issued for an assignment many years ago
that's actually really common
um i know many many journalists and
reporters who will just use an old press
pass i've done it as well
um a decade ago um sometimes it's just
hard to get a new press pass and uh you
just use an old one and that's it you're
just identified as press and that that's
basically it
um so extremely extremely tragic story
and it is getting very very serious
there including not only do we now have
journalists who have been killed
uh but there is also video which we're
not going to play because it's still
very
it's still very unclear
exactly what is allowed in terms of
footage um on youtube as well as on
instagram and facebook and a lot of the
platforms we're on but there is now
footage of uh from mario paul
of what appears to be and it has not
been it has not been contested at this
point uh russian tanks just firing upon
um a civilian apartment building now
will the russians later say well we
believed it to be a base of operations
for i don't know they've not said it yet
um and the video has not been contested
so this is all getting very ugly and in
the midst of this we have conflicting
reports on the one hand there are
reports that progress has been made on a
potential serious ceasefire and peace
talks between ukraine and russia
that's good news if it's true at the
same time there are reports being widely
publicized that vladimir putin is now
looking to escalate the war
seeking military equipment from china
could both be true
sure
it continues to move very quickly
and by the
by wednesday or thursday we should have
a sense as to whether the reports of the
ceasefire talks getting closer uh is
accurate because typically those don't
take more than a few days from what a
number of different experts are saying
we will follow it let me know on twitter
at dpakman what you expect for the week
ahead